now in conclusion
i wish to address
one other very different issue one that
is widely regarded as having
altered the very nature of museums as
institutions
i refer to a phenomenon that has
variously been characterized as the
museum going from being mission driven
to market driven
or put another way from collection
driven to audience focused
with the primary emphasis now on the
social contract
it is worth quoting here the late
stephen weil of the smithsonian
the most prominent apologist
for this paradigm shift
he applauds and i quote him
that collections
historically viewed as the center of
museum activities have now moved toward
a supporting role
as no longer the primary measure of
value for a museum rather it is service
to its public that has become the core
measuring stick end of quote
in noting the gradual change in the
museum from repository to activity
center
what is really meant is a shift in
emphasis from the experience of art
to the experience of the museum itself
to a holistic approach that embraces
first the amenities many of which in
themselves are a good thing
the programs the ancillary offerings
from shops to cafeterias music poetry
dance in the galleries and so forth
how far we have come or slipped from the
ideals expressed at the birth of the
museum in the age of enlightenment was
well expressed by carl friedrich
schinkel
the architect of the altus museum in
berlin around 1830 when he proclaimed
that his grand facades and interiors
were meant as places where as he put it
this is shenkel speaking
the individual could recollect himself
and prepare himself for the mysteries
that awaited him
it was not to be a social place
but rather a place where the individual
divorced himself from society
you'll notice that it do not include in
my list of extraneous amenities the new
electronic media
such as websites
because for me this is mostly the museum
for ilimura
unambiguously supplemental and useful
where computer screens encroach on the
exhibits themselves as happens more and
more that is another matter
what i was speaking of in referring to
all these amenities and their often
aggressive promotion
is a shift in emphasis
where so much more attention seems to be
devoted to what surrounds the work of
art rather than to the work of art
itself the phenomenon that the eminent
art historian ernst gombrich described
or decried as
the museum killing admiration with
kindness
this is a shift that i have myself on
occasion rude
wondering if hector's exhortation in
shakespeare's troilus and cressida might
not be to the point
it is mad idolatry
to make the service greater than the god
today with a little distance perhaps i
am prepared to be to be truthful rather
more indulgent
first because i have become increasingly
impatient with snobbishness and
self-righteousness
and second because if we're really
willing to look objectively
on the whole
museums have kept their extraneous
activities largely separate from where
the art is shown
are the ancillary activities and their
promotion really so dominant as to be a
distraction to the appreciation of art
or on the contrary a perfectly suitable
even effective invitation to such
appreciation
so the deeper question
should be
would we not have more faith in the
power of the work of art to transcend
these possible distractions
and in the visitors own ability to to
transcend them
let's face it
promotional efforts and overwatch
rhetoric are often no more than that
we are after all in a world where
communication and marketing are
ubiquitous and dominant but experience
shows us
that they do produce results and in the
end they can serve the mission both
democratic and pluralistic
for the range of responses to art of
course is likely to be as varied as the
audiences are diverse
some will respond aesthetically others
in a learned fashion some will be
bemused other indifferent
and some will respond somatically this
is a somatic response using the body
and then others will respond for the
record
obviously
a museum can't arrange things to try and
anticipate all these responses
but it has done its job if it provides
through a thoughtful
pleasing and intelligent installation
the conditions for that unhurried
inquisitive gaze without which we cannot
live fully the work of art
the capacity of the eye to see the whole
image in literally the blink of an eye
makes it very difficult as we all know
to devote to any work of art the
requisite time
and it is a matter of time
for that searching and inquiring look
and perhaps before a work of art we
should consider intoning
as if to oneself
as well
as to the work of art that krieduker
of faust at the end of gerter's tale
for violet
way to linger thou art so fair
because it is hard to linger
museums it's in their inherently
contradictory
contradictory nature do not make it easy
for the work of art to detain the eye
they show them to so many people at once
in so many compelling progressions from
gallery to gallery this has the virtue
of course of allowing us to grasp much
of the complexity and character of a
culture a style an artist
but
a museum must almost must also promote
the experience of a singularity
encourage a truly meaningful colloquy
between visitor and work of art a
conversation
leisurely
even intense
and one from which its antecedence in
the wunderkammer
should also not be forgotten
and that is the sense of wonder
thank you
you